for as long as there have been humans
there's been
War whilst we can hope that a thousand
years from now we'll all have matured
into hoverboard riding pacifists for the
time being murdering each other in the
name of whatever disagreements
fashionable this decade seem set to
remain an intrinsic part of who we are
probably the most devastating acts of
violence ever to have been carried out
by humans on humans were the atomic
bombings of the Japanese cities of
hoshima and Nagasaki at the tail end of
the second world war the weapons that
caused his mass destruction were
codenamed little boy and fat man
respectively and between them they
claimed somewhere in the region of
200,000 lives but what's a little less
well known is that this deadly Duo was
very nearly a
trio